si vous kiffez les arénas francophone
n'hésitez pas à mettre un petit pouce
bleus en replay et on va jouer écouter
hommage une française contre louis léon
va un petit peu changé on va un petit
peu modifié les françaises
beaucoup de ça change des gens nés
français arena francophones ont fait une
française donc fait une variante d'
avance donc la française toujours pareil
l'inquiète davantage des plans celle
avantages des espaces est ce que les
noirs veulent faire ses contre-attaqués
le sang dans un deuxième temps et le
gros problème des noirs c'est le fou de
cases blanches qu'on essaye généralement
de sortir un jour sur la diagonale
b 5 enfin à 6 à 6 f1 pour l'échanger
contre le fou de cash blanche qui est
une arme très dangereuse pour les
membres ce que ce fou il peut faire des
sacrifices et faire des sacrifices
c'était la fin de la phrase donc d'un v6
on se place alors à faire pire a lieu
sept
je pense que peut-être prendre ici en c5
on va voir s'il le fait je crois que
quand on met le cavalier de vent dans
les ventes d'avant s'il ya un moment où
les blancs peuvent éventuellement
prendre avec l'idée de jouer avec la
casse des 4 après
et de consolider le pion d'une manière x
ou y donc il prend ses cinq je pense que
c'est bien joué c'est peut-être pour ça
que j'aurais dû prendre en d4 mais
j'avais envie de voir ce qu'ils
faisaient donc la dame leurs parents à 5
et maintenant on veut jouer un truc
comme cavalier g6 s'en prendre aux pions
et puis finir le développement ça doit
se jouer aussi ainsi continuer à
attaquer madame je repartirai versé 7
comme ça je remettrai la pression je
vais je vais essayer de 2 voilà devant
prendre vraiment au pion qui est quand
même son point faible ici kébé 3 adams
et 7 donc je replace mes pièces vous
voyez complètement pour jouer contre le
point faible de l'adversaire son endroit
le moins protégés le pion est ici by me
le donne donc écoutez moi quand on me
donne je prends quand on me donne je
prends à noter quand il ya des fois être
capturés toujours des cavalières trois
échecs
alors est-ce que c'est très efficace ici
je sais pas mais ça permet de le montrer
j'ai du cavaliere trois échecs et 1 3 et
4 ce qui me permet de ba de prendre le
fou de cases noires qui peut être une
pièce importante pour moi vu que c'est
la paire de fouet que sur les cases
noires je suis peut-être un peu faim
mais qu on voit là méfions centraux sont
sur blanc donc prendre le foot 15 heures
c'est pas mal y apprend le cavalier je
vais reprendre du pillon je vais
renforcer le centre est comme ça je vais
pouvoir mettre mon fiancé 5 pour venir
contrôler la case des quatre donc là
j'ai une position quand même très
agréable avec les noirs et c'est pas mal
le petit switch en fait sur le pion aux
cinq donc là il s'en prend à rien du
tout mais je vais faire quand même un
petit c5 ou pas ou alors à commencer par
food et 6 on va garder le truc solide on
fera c'est 5 ou 1 5 4 plus tard d'une
tête on chassera avait que 5 4
là on en profite pour faire une petite
menace de ma discrète donc il semble
qu'il va jouer g3 offre adam f 16 dont
il pourra faire bouger de au pire on
fera de 5,4 et on mettra la marche avant
au centre il fait dame b 3 et donc la
fête vous la main ou faites-vous les
pieds d'un proche de échec et mat donc
partie tranquille sur louis du lit je
passe sur les cautions par rapport à
cette partie que ce soit sur youtube en
commentaires n'hésitez pas à me demander
mais ici ouais je pense juste le truc
important c'était le le switch sur le
pion aux cinq as peut-être qu'il aurait
fallu qu'ils jouent à je ne sais pas
exactement comment il doit jouer ici un
ace que prises on sait 5 était juste à
première vue ça me paraît être le coup
mais après peut-être qu'il fallait vite
protéger ce pion et ce qu'il pouvait
faire un truc genre froid f4 qui étaient
ici sous j'ai trois dames c'est cet etf
ou quelque part genre fou b5
peut-être je veux pas trop m'avancer
parce que je sais pas bon peut-être il
ya des gens qui connaissent mieux mais
c'est vrai qu'après il s'est retrouvé
mal avec le pion à l'est on va essayer
d'enchaîner avec une deuxième partie on
joue contre des ennemis via écouter unis
via j'ai envie de rejouer une française
si je le peux alors on va faire des 4 e
6 quand même on peut on peut jouer ça ça
peut être un leurre de coût qui peut
nous permettre de faire un stonewall en
évitant certaines variantes dans l'eau
lambèse je crois en tout cas une on va
faire un petit stonewall comme ça on
fait un répertoire à un petit peu
différent voilà encore un les ordres de
coûts les mecs franchement si vous
voulez jouer cette ouverture la regarde
et je suis pas un spécialiste je fais ça
pour un peu changé pour essayer de
donner des idées mais stonewall c'est
vraiment pas ma spécialité
alors là fondamentalement les blancs
quand même perdu du temps ce que je
prends un f4 non j'ai pas envie de
prendre un f casse qui va faire école
que j'aurais peut-être pu faire mais bon
j'ai l'argent qui est une variante ou
est ce qui a permis un tempo jeu c'est
pas vraiment mais écoutez moi je vais
mettre un cavalier le cas du vermette ça
enlève 6 et je vais essayer de faire
passer le fou par 17,8 et j'ai 80 mètres
ça ici il ya probablement faire cavalier
ou 5 je vais faire food et cette fois 8
mai au tour en séance n'a pas l'air mal
je vais essayer de faire passer le fou
par là bas
si prend des cinq je reprendrai de alors
il prend en otage machin c'est pas une
réussite ce stones voilà pour le mans
c'est plus une réussite pour mon
adversaire m'a écouté on va jouer le
plan même si j'aurais plutôt prix du
cavalier mais on va laisser faire on va
voir un peu comment et comment ils
progressent pour le moins il joue bien
et se stonewall est loin d'être une
réussite je pense qu'ils me donnent une
complètement le fourrage 5 et très
mauvais je vais jouer un mauvais fou
qu'on bon cavalier normalement je vais
la perdre donc on voit exactement ce
qu'il fallait pas faire mais c'est vrai
qu'avec le fou qui sorti rapidement
c'était pas terrible alors eu quatre à
mon avis c'est une petite erreur parce
que j'ai cavaliers 3 qui m'a l'air
sympathique alors c'est pas fait encore
mais ça fait quand même une fourchette
et il ya des quatre ans prises en plus
donc ça a l'air d'être sympathique on va
pouvoir prendre en f1 il prend aussi son
affaire roi à suite il y aura jamais
problème kiev 7 parce que j'ai foot pro
f 7 et en plus tu ailles adam prend des
quatre qui arrive incessamment sous peu
et qui risque de faire très mal
mais mauvaise partie pour moi il aurait
pu il m'a bien dominé par à quel moment
et j'ai mal joué je sais pas mais le
stonewall fois que je regarde un peu si
je veux jouer parce que là c'était pas
ça mais normalement qu'on le poussait un
sort c'est pas terrible
ces histoires de sony voilà il fait foot
france et sa grange je ne comprends pas
du tout ce que c'est juste faire dame
prend des 4es d'impro 5
j'espère que je rate rien voilà je
comprends plus rien du tout et coups de
l'adversaire là me choque
bon pousser les pions
et on va essayer tranquillement gagné
donc oui ainsi s'en va bien blindé mais
j'ai un peu de mal avec le stonewall je
suis pas un spécialiste du saosnois là
honnêtement c'est pas mon ouverture
fétiche c'est dur à jouer mais ça peut
être intéressant on réessaiera mais je
crois quand le fou sort c'est pas
terrible où là il ya peut-être vous
prend h7 la franchise fff 7 mai c'est
pas glorieux mais wii fit plus est en
train de paille stone wall way pascal
tour ça soit un peu suspect ouais c'est
un peu juste moi je joue mal avec les
vents avec les noirs au moins - j'ai pas
je fais pas de jaloux avec le stonewall
je joue mal avec les deux couleurs aux
marques s'appuie par des ouvertures un
chef je joue je joue mal avec toutes les
couleurs
je joue mal avec toutes les couleurs
j'ai changé mon donc souvent contre une
position gagnante il faut juste échangé
les pièces dont clara mettre le foin fc
doyon va on va on va provoquer les
échanges auront fait un semis clouage
dans le sens où s'y prend on va mater
donc on va le forcer encore pas en force
les échanges en fait on force les
échanges des sacs chaque échange nous
favorisent pas ce que maintenant on va
enfin on est une tour de plus net donc
plus on échange de pièces puis c'est
facile à jouer - ya de pièges donc là on
fait tous rue 8 on veut jouer pour les
changes et il abandonne n'est donc quoi
elle se stonewall ses marques passard
ouais pourquoi le vix est mal car et
c'est peut-être jusqu'ici ça allait mais
bon en fait on reste avec une mauvaise
pièce et à ce moment là juste ça va être
très visuel pour vous je vais essayer de
vous montrer un truc vraiment 18e à la
faune voilà c'est ici je vais vous
montrer faut prendre les 5 et pourquoi
ça s'est mal passé je rade mais ton je
sais pas moi de me prendre et si on
compare le curieux cinq os x 5 on voit
immédiatement que les noirs sont
forcément très mal ce qu'il ya un cavani
qui est bien placé au centre est une
pieuvre il ya un fou qui a du mal à
trouver trouver de l'avenir en fait il a
il a pas de diagonale
si vous réfléchissez a pas vraiment de
bons endroits et peut pas faire de
bonnes choses donc ça c'est vraiment le
scénario cauchemar c'est quand on se
retrouve dans le stonewall par exemple
va prendre
voilà on va prendre cette position alors
à prendre cette position le cauchemar en
fait c'est que ça un fouet un cavalier
s'échange contre deux cavaliers et se
prend le car ayant eu 5 c'est le
cauchemar et c'est ce que mon adversaire
a réussi à faire après il s'est fait
magouilles et voilà et ça s'est bien
passé pour moi mais mais sinon sinon
j'étais mal et mon adversaire m'a donné
une petite leçon stratégique qui s'est
finalement bien finir à jouer une
variante marrante que vlad m'a montré
quand on parle quand on est en train de
préparer notre dvd sur les pions isolé
alors qui est loin d'être finie encore
mais on a un peu parlé des purs isolé
donc ça me donne envie de jouer le
contre un pur isolé avec la française
alors si on a un adversaire français 3
je vais reprendre de b vous voyez on
peut obtenir comme ça une position avec
une française une position qui n'est pas
une position de française du tout
[Musique]
donc une position complètement
différente ce qui peut être intéressant
lorsque vous jouez contre des joueurs de
française parce que ça peut les mettre
un peu dans l'embarras ça leur fait
jouer une structure de pions qui
connaissent pas forcément et ça peut
être assez intéressant
donc c'est un peu l'idée de cette
variante
alors alors le missclick je suis pas sûr
d'avoir bien placé les pièces au delà du
mythe clic parce que c'était peut-être
un peu dommage mais c'est clouage me l'a
évidemment je suis très mal ouais là je
suis forcément très mal leur a forcément
l'album missclick pareil carrés en plus
en dans ce genre de position faut jouer
actifs et où avec le pion isolé c'est
une catastrophe
alors comment est-ce qu'on va s'en
sortir mais écoutez moi je pense qu'on
va donner le pion ce genre de mix clic
fait très mal évidemment ça c'est
internet c'est comme ça on sait quand tu
joues sur intérêt surtout capable il
n'ya pas le take back sur check point
com donc je donne le pion pas trop le
choix
mais on va chercher de l'activité
l'activité s'est vidée bon gm est une
tour en d1
là on est vraiment très malin même si ce
bien joué je vais prendre je vais faire
voir de royan 3 je vais essayer de
replacer mon roi
on aime énormément amusé clic ça change
toute la partie c'est vraiment très
compliqué de le faire 1 4
je sais faire à 5 jeux c'est prendre un
peu d espace qui est des segments on va
tenter cavalier e 4 waouh c'est
peut-être très mauvais
dans les abers sur-le-champ fait bon je
suis pas sûr qu'il ait bien joué ça
parce que du coup il rentre dans une
position un peu déséquilibré mais ouais
c'est tellement gagnant ouais non c'est
beaucoup trop gagnant pour les noirs
ouais celui ci qui aura coûté cher
on va essayer de la tenir quand même
après la pression est un peu
déséquilibré mais bon c'est tellement la
cata j'ai essayé de placer les mal placé
les pions noirs mais en fait c'est assez
ridicule quoi c'est trop gagnant fait
pour les noirs c'est beaucoup trop
gagnant
remonté le roi bon après c'est un miss
quelqu'un on n'y peut rien c'est les
aléas du jeu sur internet
c'était vraiment un mystique dans une
mauvaise situation
on ne peut pas créer deux contres jeu
rien la pression est tellement affreuse
c'est comme ça c'est la vie
on peut rien faire
ignoble
c'est ignoble on va abandonner bon
dommage dans le mystique aura coûté cher
aux hommages pu faire une partie sans
pas on a perdu du temps impression était
vraiment wedia bien un bienfait la
finale est dommage moi je peins
jouissent position avec des miss li
qu'en fait ça mais ça m'agace un peu là
c'est un peu dommage parce que tu
essaies ça me semble un peu perdu dix
minutes de stream béjaïa battu kevin a
bien joué bon après on pourra y avait un
beau missclick du coup c'est un peu
compliqué mon num poussette cette
position j'ai fait un peu la même chose
que les purs isolé de nouveau contre la
carro cannes bon on va jouer cette
structure est ce que je vais être le
france et quatre roues en d3 je sais pas
encore on va voir des jeunes jusqu'à
quelle heure quel programme bas il faut
lire repas limpias cure intéressant lire
les titres des stream donc espérer que
ces quatre jours les plus fous en d3 va
voir comment il continue
j'aurais pu être influencé 4 aussi bien
évidemment
c'est une autre pause une position
donc à refaire fou des deux va protéger
rock rock ok le fourbe et 4 je pense pas
qu'il soit bien passé placé à terme sur
cavaliers apsys je vais faire fou j'ai
cinq et ce que je vois c'est fou proches
souhaitent non pas vraiment puisque
après qu'un léger s'inquiète un match 5
y aura toujours cavalier 6 pour défendre
ok mais ils font des six alors
maintenant j'ai le choix je peux faire
un truc pas mal je peux échanger ici et
je vois un truc symétrique
ou peut-être tu peux jouer à trois pour
commencer et voir ce qui fait cavalier
ici je vais faire foulée 5
il ya en gros je vais sûrement fous ces
deux dames détroit
et en gros je vais sûrement fous ces
deux dames des trois gt de cavaliers au
katla d'ailleurs bon
je vais sûrement faire pousser de dames
détroit et allez allez allez attaquer h7
ici et j'essaie de jouer pour dames des
trois raisons la première est la
programmation les mecs dans le chat mais
c'est la reina francophone coiffage et
reparle à bout d'un moment
enfin je sais pas faim quelle
programmation bayarena francophone 19
heures ça dure 1h30 pas je sais pas quoi
vous répondre en fait que dire quoi
alors je vais prendre une fois ici
j'aurais pu faire un truc beaucoup mieux
que ce que j'ai fait je faire cavalier
au 4 mai
qu'as-tu fait piéger 3es jeux mais je
crois que la valeur affiche 5 et ya pas
de casse pour la dame pour défendre f6
non moins que je me trompe c'est une
menace assez substantielle et sur d'amis
les quatre qui est pro f 6 même si je
pense que d'alger qu'adam g k doit être
le meilleur
ouf parce que si dame revient ici dam
des deux
les gammes prosafe 6 après
ok du coup je ramasse la dame se damne
des trois seuls coûts et le fait que ça
dure 1h30 si vous jouez l'aréna vous
allez tout de suite le savoir ce qui est
un conteur écrit avec les 1h30 en
arrêter les mecs et enfin j'essaye
d'expliquer un peu ce qui se passe pour
essayer d'être pertinents pour les gens
[Musique]
c'est poser une question intéressante
alors on joue contre crypte alors on va
retenter peut-être la française qu'on
crie tall sall est intéressant les
françaises crippen qui joue bien
du coup je suis très furieux un rien de
faire un truc j'ai envie de jouer ça
comme une française rubinstein et faire
cavalier m6 ici avec l'idée que sur
cavaliers prendre d'importantes décade
j'ai une tante fait rage 6 et donc ça
doit ainsi je connais pas du tout ça
doit égaliser cette histoire pas sûr que
c'est un bon coup ces cinq d'ailleurs ok
je vais prendre je comprends pas trop ce
qui fait pour le moment
ok il a ce petit chipeau paraît sage et
à la française c'est pas mais ouverture
et sa vie j'ai pas d'en prendre quatre
sages avaient juste pas vu et donc j'ai
peut-être un peu moins bien je fous le
set
je vais être un peu moins bien cavalier
la v5 qui avait lié à 6 donc je couve
ses sets et je veux faire rock au
prochain c'est pas beau ce que je suis
en train de faire c'est moche j'ai
oublié que j'avais pas dame prend des
cadres et donc la position est un peu
inférieure mais cette structure de pions
général ces fonds peut limiter les
dégâts quoi avoir honte et je peux avoir
comme idée de faire kébé 4 qui est des
cinq il fait d'amis ici
oui menace rien apparemment j'ai envie
de faire qui est b4 pour m'en prendre au
faou et sur food et qu'adam g 5 qu'il
peut faire bouffer la position reste
toujours un poil difficiles auxquelles
ils commencent par km c'est cet
intermédiaire qu'est ce que ça vaut cet
intermédiaire si je prends des 3i prend
à 8
je prends b2i repart ans et 7
je vais faire crisser 4 même à 6 si j'ai
envie de tenter sa plus pour la
pédagogie qu'autre chose j'ai envie de
dire ce qui doit les prendre à 8
je vais prendre mes draps il prend pas à
8 ok
à ce carrefour prend 1,7 à message est
pas du tout vu à il a bien joué là
dessus je n'ai pas du tout vu
j'ai complètement raté cette idée assez
bien joué je suis pas familier avec les
tactiques dans cette position là bon je
faire fou 17
je suis pas familier avec les tactiques
dans ses positions la sage avait
complètement raté assez joli là ce qu'il
a fait mais bon je suis pas familier
avec ses tactiques du coup du coup je me
les prend en blitz est difficile parfois
on a une qualité de moins mais la
structure de pions les meilleurs parce
qu'ils aspirent en d4 et ya pas de
colonne ouverte pour les tours ce qui
veut dire que c'est pas encore la fin
des haricots
bon les haricots sont cuits mais ils
sont pas finies ans plus tôt les
carottes qui sont cuites mais c'est pas
tout à fait fini ça joue encore 25 ans
qui est bon je veux pas échanger les
dames je veux pas ouvrir des colonnes
alors j'aurai fait tout reprend ses six
à sa place honnêtement je pense surprend
c'est si c'était vraiment fort
je vous montrerai après à mais ici à
foot365 mais je vois rien aussi je pense
que tout reprend c'est si c'était quand
même plus simple parce que la finale
était pas si clair mais bon je rate trop
tactique là pour le moment j'ai bien
joué hier soir mais là c'est dur
cependant je reste quand même sur mon
avis de tauromachie c'était plus simple
et moins risquée prix direct mais c'est
vrai que cette tactique là très bien
aussi on peut pas critiquer on va voir
si réussi à la gagner mais normalement
oui cette française qui aurait pas été
assez médiocre
malan bon un petit coup de tour des 5
pour le moment
belge radja des tactiques 1 ces petites
tactiques bon peu importe un c'est pas
très grave
et comme quoi intéressant que moi quand
je joue des
caen joue des carreaux cannes comme je
l'avais joué beaucoup quand j'étais
gamin je fais pas trop d'erreurs en fait
je connais les thèmes et ce à la
française comme j'ai jamais joué
il ya des petites choses que je connais
pas et je me prends les petits pièges
quoi est juste c'est intéressant ça ça
enfin julie ça vous montre à quel point
c'est important en fait d'eux de se
familiariser avec les thèmes tactique d
ouverture cette tour elle sert à rien la
mienne je vais essayer de prendre et de
faire dame ces deux sans grande
conviction
c'est complètement foutu mais bon si on
peut apprendre quelque chose de ça c'est
quoi en blitz surtout en partie plus
longue c'est moins grave quand vous
jouez nouvelles ouvertures et du coup ça
peut être intéressant
tu crois que tant d dans les livres
d'ouverture il ya souvent les thèmes
tactique après on les connaît à force de
les jouer en les jouant partiront ou
quoi on commence à connaître après les
thèmes tactique classique de chaque
ouverture merveille chaque ouverture à
ces petits à ces petites tables
accueillent ces sept fous prend à s'être
tu vois je vois pas trop de après côté
blanc je peux le trouver mais côté noir
ça peut être un truc moins évident pour
moi ça c'est bien joué on veut échanger
les pièces bien évidemment
et surtout le duo dam tour va être super
dangereux pour moi alors je sais pas
trop quoi faire
on n'y croit pas du tout mais je fous
des 4
sans grande conviction
je vais peut-être faire dans me2
j'essaie de de me battre je peux me
faire planter par une tactique un an
surtout prendre des cas et adam eu un
mais bon la tour se retrouve un peu
short of square peut-être pas mal ce que
je suis en train de faire je suis
peut-être en train de brouiller les eaux
qu'elle fait refouler deux tours ici feu
quatre tours f1 fou détroit et je peux
peut-être contrôler toute la première
rangée bizarrement parce que je suis en
train de faire d'ailleurs je contrôle
tout la première mais là c'est dommage
pour crypte à qui n'est pas calculé à
vendre ce qu'il a fait des coups de
tours pour la sauver et s'il avait vu
toutes ces menaces en amont il aurait
sûrement jouer un peu différemment et
c'est vrai qu'il aurait dû calculer en
fait toute cette vente avec foulée 5-fu
détroit est juste donné la qualité
direct parce que là maintenant il peut
pas faire tout reprendre les deux
gendarmes et un math
donc en fait il perd la tournette bon
alors il tenta un dernier piège mais je
leur fais fou prend f6 et au final ça
mène à rien il va j'espère la partie à
cause de ce piège qui était sympa alors
la partie n'était pas exceptionnel mais
juste
oui en fait tour c5 c'est un peu
paradoxal mais après tout reprend prises
et dams et 2 j'avais cette impression là
que c'est ça devenait peut-être un peu
bizarre je fais un peu bizarre c'est
bien géré tout pour moi échangerait
cette tour fait l'idée fondamentale
c'est que la tour non blancs je pouvais
pas rentrer facilement sur la colonne
des et je voulais taper à deux pour
essayer d'avoir un plan c'est à dire
prendre b3 et poussé le pion à et après
way ses prix ce petit piège west ham 2
qui est assez jolie d'ailleurs il a tour
à plus de cases en fait toute la
première rangée avec le fou blanc
détroit va être prise en fait toutes les
cases vont être prises et le fou en b2
en fait on va prendre toutes les cases
et on récupère la qualité
donc c'était pas mal
ça situe déçoit ces derniers jours par
toi tu dis un peu hautain mais bon eh
ben dis non c'est expliquer les parties
qu'on joue à fond ses hôtes un désolé
désolé d'être hautain et de vouloir
expliquer aux gens comment je joue au
maximum tu vois j'essaye d'être
concentré là dessus et dan des 3 way et
peut-être dam des trois mais d'amd
troyat dame prend f2 et d'un étranger de
maths françois jacq
non mais bon
c'est un club thierry fischer c'est c c
et anne sinquin pas voulu jouer
allez on va refaire une française gpo je
me suis trompé tout à l'heure alors
variantes des changes
bon je vais faire un petit truc un peu
simple ah je pensais qu'ils allaient
jouer avec
je pensais que j'allais jouer avec foot
est roi ok ça pousse un endroit fonds
allèles dame pardon donc je vais faire b
si je vais essayer de casser il va faire
b4 je vais faire à 5 donc je vais
essayer de casser son ça pousse ses
pions
ok je vais mettre un cavalier e 4 ça
mange pas de pain comme ça je m'en
prends un peu à ça donc sfr f6 comme ça
je contrôle un peu des cases encore et
je vais jouer cavalier je peux prendre
et faire qu'ils étaient sept sinon je
faire qu'à l'idée cette année je vais
essayer vraiment m'en prendre à ce truc
là pour le pousser à faire a b c d et es
jouer et jouer pour ces 5
tu faire fuji 6,6 me cloue je vais me
des clous et comme ça je suis plus que
louer ici s'y prend de façon je reprends
du fou
ouais je vais essayer d'afficher le
classement et anne est ce que je peux
placer un clip relève de ici parce que
son fouet plus protégés qui est bref de
j'attaque la dame il bouge je vous
prends des trois n'est peut-être pas
lindsay se rend pas compte que ça
demande beaucoup de concentration de
faire ce que je fais en fait part à sam
on demande beaucoup peut-être parce que
je suis nul ce qui est plus que possible
mais ça demande beaucoup de
concentration et donc du coup tu as les
questions auxquelles on peut trouver des
semis réponse ou quoi
quand on reçoit 10 par jour au bout d'un
moment futures y en a un peu marre quoi
surtout que c'est toujours le même truc
tous les vendredis dans que l'on alors
maintenant il veut jouer pour pions
prendrait pour prince et si ce qui est
intéressant si j'ai change tout ans et
5e fait tout reprend ses cinq et il
obtient un truc je peux faire des cinq
tours e6 kébé 8
c'est un peu passif mais je pourrais
chasse et parfois vii par la suite est
ce que jamais avec b5 c'est que du coup
son cavalier ses cavaliers en fait on
plus de cases de 2
ils sont bizarres en fait ces cavaliers
là après les 5 eca f1 je vais vite vite
vite colmatée la colonne eux pour pas
laisser tours 6 écoute ce que je disais
ses cavaliers ont besoin d'un peu de
temps pour rebondir alors il rebondit de
l'autre côté c'est tant mieux je vais
rebondir moi aussi véreux 6 et je vais
pouvoir sortir madame vers 17 ski est
sympa tosh l'importance auquel son
cavalier la a beaucoup de mal à revenir
en jeu en fait j'ai quasiment envie
juste de prendre ici et faire dame 17
j'avais pas envie de voir le truc arrive
en d6 lequel il sera activé en c5 même
si même même au prix d'un sacrifice
d'options je préfère laisser son
cavalier je préfère laisser son cavalier
un peu idiot sur cette case
allez je vais mettre le cavalier en
angers 6 j'ai hésité avec le 6 pour
attaquer des quatre minutes façon son
cavalier de défense bref des duels en
russie je ne sais pas mais bon je veux
juste échangé en fait le long de cette
colonne et pour le moment ça me paraît
sain patoche hockey
il ya fouet f4 maintenant on va s'en
prendre à ça c'est enfin genre de
clouage et peut-être un jour sur tour
des ans on fait tout reprend 20 fonds
prend à faut 3 est encore floue f2 on
est un poil short mais on peut faire
tour est vite du coup on a gagné la
colonne eux grâce à ce subterfuge donc
alors comment on progresse encore
je vais faire flouer trois échecs web de
forcer fou prend f2 prise f de cavale et
f4 damev trois dames f5 essayé ok
j'étais petit tour deux échecs mais
tours de roue en f1 tout rejet d'un f4
d'un match 3
ça sent bon aussi parce que je six tours
de saint-ours g2 d'un f4 bon on va faire
simple affaire de la mnef 5 avec hideki
et détroit d'un pro b 2 qui est privé de
ce que si on tape b 2 en plus on gagne
la casse c quatre et on menace aussi sur
roy g1 peut-être cavaliers prendre 2 qui
prend là bas au caire qui recule et que
le cavale autant dire que ça commence à
sentir très très bon avec une tour en e2
donc ils sacrifient la dame et du coup
ça va gagner tranquillement alors d'un
me quatre échecs cavale de trois ans
fera e55 f4 on va pousser les pions faut
attaquer le roi de toute façon quand
vous avez la dame contre les pièces
mineur par un complice mineur et tours
ou contre des pièces mineur il faut
toujours s'en prendre au roi parce que
le roi ça fait des échecs quand on
l'attaqué la voyez on a déjà gratter
tous les pions et maintenant on va
envoyer de plongée et là on a un petit
damas trois échecs comme toujours la
dame face aux pièces sa fédé double
attaque
ça c'est gagner alors on va essayer de
se prendre le classement du tournoi
comme nous l'a demandé et anne
ces deux cadres et sa tranquille où on
va y retourner
alors on rejoue contre monsieur dafri on
va faire un petit coup de cavalia si
cette fois ci on va un peu changer fouet
4 et alors on va faire b5 on va jouer un
peu ce truc bizarre ça va un peu changer
mon idée c'est de contrôler f4 ses
cartes avec le pion et aux quatre avec
les pièces donc on se blinde le pion le
pion des cinq et on va m'en apprendre et
on va les jouer avec fougue et cette par
la suite c'est pas très bon mais ça
change
les pions à 6 pas si mal placé quelque
part parce qu'il empêche qui a et b 5 1
dans les échanges en d4 voir un peu
comment ça se développe
bon ce pas une superbe ouverture un spa
terrils honnêtement ça permet juste de
sortir de l'ouverture rapidement d'un
prend des gars que j'aime pas je
penserai prendre avec le pion avec le
cavalier puisque ça donne un tempo
gratuit et je vais pouvoir jouer avec
des cinq après peut-être en gagner
encore un deuxième sur le fou et s'il
fait d'amd devant même peut-être fou b4
et cava lieu 4 s'est déjà essayé de
gagner cinq sites m15 système tôt
j'exagère mais 2,3 tempo sur
l'adversaire le cresson l'anah et pour
le moment c'est anne qui domine
non je vais quand même faire des 5
c'est un petit coup de foudre et 6
je n'ai peut-être pas un grand coup ok
rock comme ça ça a permis de
voyez en l'espace de 2-3 cougé régler
mes problèmes de développement alors
tour c'est un jeu met le fond p7 pour le
moment peut-être un jour j'ai réussi à
pousser au 5
si je veux cinquième rang des saints qui
est prend des saints qui pourra faire
dame prend des 5 et j'ai pas de bonnes
découvertes
auxerre faut que je réussisse à protéger
sa plus ici je fais fou prend qui on
prend 1,5 et prend le cac et prend des 5
j'ai toujours pas d'intermédiaire c'est
toujours le même problème nature pas
d'intérieur qui marche donc pour le
moment peut-être un coup comme tour des
huit peut être malin avec qui des fous
prend qui on prend
et j'ai envie de tenter eux 5 je suis
pas sûr que ça marche et ça a été
intéressant pour tout le monde de quatre
pays des cieux cavaliers prends je veux
faire le 4 est maintenant sûr cavaliers
prend dame prend la grande différence
c'est que ça ça reste en prise en fait
c'est que ça c'est que le public a très
protégée sur fou pranger cavaliers b4
rami a peut-être fou prend f7 ok donc
fou prend caraïbes et 4 fou prend f7 roi
preuve cette dame c'est quatre échecs
cavaliers des 5 et 4 dames c'est 7 pour
attaquer la dame et dames b3 le
cavaliere est flou et donc fou prend des
cinq ces critiques ne sont clairement
fait de calculer qui prend des cinq
dames prend des cinq forcé sur cahier
prend 1,4 et j'ai peut-être rien il a
fait cavalier ici au caire question ch 6
mais c'est intéressant comme position
alors qu'elle prend fc 3 1er set qui est
prend des cinq qui prend des cinq d'un
prend des cinq dames prend des 5 fu
prend des cinq essais 6 passes emprise
ouais du coup cette idée avec des cinq
avait que 5
j'ai pensé que ça pouvait être graves
parce que ça fait un peu peur mais je
voulais essayer calcul avec vous
histoire qu'on discute un peu l'arnaqué
price est prise à vii et qu'elle prend
des cinq as écouté bravo à lui 1 c'est
bien joué alors qu'il prend des 5
j'ai encore eu f8
j'ai encore roy et fuite ça pue
complètement effet une bonne partie 1
j'y crois pas le roi est trop faible
foulée 3 sur la diagonale je pense que
c'est très bien pour les blancs mais
c'est intéressant du coup du coût 1,5
était une faute c'est bien ce qu'on
pensait mais ç'a permis de calcul
ensemble et de voir des variantes c'est
l'objectif de ces trucs
ok dame g6 donc il veut jouer pour mater
away c'est très bien joué et du coup
surprise prise y aurait des problèmes en
c6 vrai mais je vais la perdre bref une
belle partie et finale perdante belle
partie mais bon comme visée jeu j'avais
le pressentiment que la rente marché pas
mais ça permettait de 2 voilà de
discuter d'un peu cette position
ensemble après je sais pas si vous ça
vous plaît que parfois je joue des
mauvais enfin des mauvais suis pas sûr
que ce soit mauvais mais que je joue des
trucs qui sont pas terrible terrible
pour essayer de réfléchir avec vous et
puis discuté des variantes mais j'ai pas
en fait il ça vous plaît ou pas mais moi
ça me paraît intéressant de le faire ça
permet d' un peu plus réfléchir aux
oppositions ensemble et puis de voir les
tactiques au lieu de - a calculé de mon
côté et dire ah bah ça marche pas que
l'on voit pas vraiment pourquoi
et là c'est sympa parce que les
adversaires parfois il réfute et je
trouve ça personnellement intéressant
mais après c'est comme tout peut-être
que ça n'intéresse que moi
nous sommes par avoir une petite
pédagogie un petit intérêt et puis ça
change un peu des stream tête que vous
regardez je passe sur les autres chaînes
tête ils font pas trop ça parce que les
gens aiment pas trop se met en
difficulté généralement est calculée
trop de la rente pour les adversaires
donc j'imagine que c'est pas quelque
chose de super comment leurs essais des
changes et une paire de tours
bizarrement on va le faire et ça je
pense pas que ce soit bon ce qui me fait
monter le roi et du coup ça ne s'était
pas très bien joué je vous fais tour
s'est vite pour éviter de me faire mater
et maintenant je veux faire un échec ici
et je vais calais une tour là et surtout
rejet cinq échecs je fais 3 e 6 et je
vais prendre une fois touriste y
réussissent du coup j'attaque partout
ils montent de faire un échec et je vais
faire un match j'ai quand même réussi à
gagner mais c'était serré en fait je
fais des petites erreurs pas forcément
exprès je fais des trucs je pense que ça
peut ne pas marcher et que ça pourrait
marcher puis j'essaie de comprendre avec
vous pourquoi ça peut ne pas marcher
et si l'adversaire joue bien et qui
réfute en fait quelque part tant mieux
parce qu'on voit des variantes
intéressantes
donc c'est un peu l'objectif est l'idée
de ce truc là donc on a une flèche nikov
ah oui alors c'est devant je connais pas
pas je sais que ça existe mais je sais
pas jouer et je sais que c'est dangereux
on est dans la merde les mecs pas je la
sens pas ce alain bolla ça c'est
vraiment dangereux comme position c'est
marrant c'est pas un truc que j'ai
l'habitude de rencontrer
mais ça c'est très mauvais ouais ça va
perdre en ligne cette histoire je vais
me faire massacrer ou pas il vaut mieux
connaître la théorie quand j'ai genre de
truc c'est marrant parce qu'on joue
contre des mecs entre guillemets de mon
niveau il joue moins ses variantes l'a
donc même si je connais pas et que j'ai
pas trop étudié j'ai réussi à m'en
sortir bon là on va voir ça peut passer
en fait prendre ces trois prendre ces
trois à prendre ces 3 il y aurait dû x 3
échecs tour b 1 je pense que ça va plus
ou moins je sais que sa vente est
dangereuse quand tu connais pas je
devins bloquer un utilisateur
dommage on va voir
alors il fait faux ici écoutez j'ai
envie de me débarrasser de ce truc ça me
fera des vacances
prendre la dame
ok j'ai envie de tenter un truc jolie
j'ai 6 x 6 échecs 3g 8 d'un prend b4
avec l'idée sur quel point b 4 carrés
lieu sept matches si ça passe j'ai pas
tout calculé m mais dans l'idée j'aime
bien
ok il prend du coup je re prend du fou
plutôt songer ici je pensais jamais trop
une idée ok ok ça c'est pas mal joué
mais ce que je peux venir à sigean
racheta tu fais fausse ça est ok même si
ça me crève le coeur je faire dame 4
pourquoi ça me crève le coeur ce que son
roi et un peu mal placé ça me crève le
coeur des changes et les dames et
peut-être que madame wayne on s'est
peut-être qu'on en fait d'avoir fait ça
mais bon j après je pourrais rejouer
avec f4 peut-être ouvrir quand même son
roi récents voire est sensiblement mal
bon j'avais envie de jouer avec kafka
donc je le fais façon fous ces cinq
échecs sont rois h1 sait rien de très
grave
quel jeu ici une fois il reprend je met
le plan c 3 quand même parce que le pian
c3 ce que j'aime bien c'est qui blindent
contre le fouet la tour après c'est
peut-être pas le coup le plus précis
direct mais juste tu as psychologique
fin
pédagogiquement j'ai envie de dire ça
bloque voilà c'est marrant parce qu'il
veut à tour h5 mais j'ai foulé 6 donc ya
pas de tour h5 et mon idée maintenant
c'est peut-être tour f 5 tours f1 et mon
tout va bien et que j'ai pas fait parce
qu'il a g6
pour le moment je veux juste prendre des
casses de partout et voir tour des 1
tour 17 c'est peut-être l'idée tout
bêtement façon j'ai les foubrac et vous
voyez sur l'ale dame est allée droit il
ya ça qui peut pas sortir et c'est
important que j'aie le petit fou g6 fait
ça j'ai juste fait retour des 1
il n'ya pas tour des huit pas ce que je
fais un clin d'oeil aux cavale et là je
veux juste tour 17 en réalité ok ça
c'est bien joué de sa part
ok ça j'avais pas pensé et c'est très
bon coup
ouais c'est bien joué ça j'ai déjà j'ai
raté ça un petit manque de précisions
ici
[Musique]
qui rend les choses pas si simple
les retours des deux pour le moment bien
jouer un leroy au set j'ai oublié en
fait ce coup russell s'est très bien
joué je prends un peu la température je
vois ce qui se passe place un peu des
choix un cavalier ici je pense que c'est
pas bien joué je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que c'est roland sa menace
un peu c'est vrai je fais un petit coup
de tours d un de toute façon qu'ils
essaient 4g tour 17 et bon j'y crois pas
du tout pour lui
qu'est ce que je peux me permettre de
faire un truc du joli faire intéressant
prendre prendre prendre et jouets food
et 5 parce que c'est gagnant cette
finale je suis pas sûr mais c'est
intéressant
lisez ce faire une focale sur le
cavalier je menaçais vii et sur f 6 gb 4
lapointe la petite pointe tactique assez
jolie d'ailleurs années m'ont fait de la
pédagogie 1 donc bon
l'agent lui dire c'est très pédagogique
ça c'est fait d'un logique comme truc
hein le l'idée de de faire la focale sur
le sur le cavalier c'est de la pédagogie
j'ai envie de dire en embarquant dans
cette finale qui est gagnante mais il
faut encore gagner mais un cas
intéressant en gros on n'est pas là pour
cette finale quoi maintenant on va
essayer de la transformer mes joueurs
par là qu'on a on est on était là pour
pour l'enchaînement pédagogique qui
était somme toute assez sympa par moi
j'ai trouvé sympa après j'ai pas dans le
chat si fou des cinq là et là bim que
vous êtes gagnant faut ramasser les
pions et on a ramassé
allez il faut passer s'est ramassé on a
créé le mur de glace
le roi est immobile les fous c'est
vraiment fort et là c'est un vrai mur et
on va aller gratter les pions ok entre
otages sains du coup il a faibli et là
c'est tout qui tombe le roi est coupé du
jeu
finale 2 pions tranquille et il était
leader du tournoi
c'est un an qui est leader on le suit et
on a battu faithless peach up pour moi
sa partie qu'on a perdu c'était le mahou
sip bon joue pas mal hein ce soir on
joue pas mal bref bon la partie est
intéressante
je trouve qu'il est pas mal de choses
intéressantes dans cette partie mais le
fou des 5 avec l'idée des quatre bons
c'est honnêtement c'est quelque chose à
avoir vu quoi
vraiment c'était un thème en thème
intéressant tu peu près je suis pas
parié date un bug alors à jouer contre
états membres à faire le 4,6 des 4 alors
qui des deux jeux vous ce centre binh
stein toujours pensé que ça manquait un
peu d'ambition cette histoire là
ces trois là on essaie de jouer pour
attaquer le roi
développer peut-être échangeant décapité
six échantillons des quinze jours une
dame on sait si ça l'a fait un bond à
avoir ça a pas l'air d'être grandiose
pour moi pour le moment mais bon
position que joue bien qui est noir
qu'avec les blancs d'ailleurs à
l'échangé des changes il échangé les
changes
et là j'ai pensé sur tf6 dams et 6 c à
vendre que j'ai peut-être juste marmonné
peut-être la rente que j'ai marmonné tu
vas si j'ai vraiment eu à verbaliser ses
variantes
mesdames c'est si ça me paraissait fort
parce que sur dante 7g dct 1.8 et sur
cavaillé c'est s'agit d'un procès 7 et
sur roy est figé d'un procès cet objet
me semble que je gagne plus ou moins un
pion par tous parce qu'évidemment sera
un grand plaisir
une petite dame sait si c'est anne qui
l'a raté d'ailleurs s'ils jouent le psy
joue la gagne dans le tournoi et tania
peut-être intérêt à abandonner essayer
de gagner la prochaine un truc que j'ai
fait dans pas mal d'arena c'est-à-dire
de passe de pas s'enfoncer dans une
position comme ça et de witte de vitesse
et d'enchaîner les parties parce qu'ils
les premiers voiliers les leaders donc
si vous voulez des arénas vous êtes
leader et cette position là la partie
peut être encore assez longue
en plus moi je suis en mode pédagogique
donc je vais pas forcément essayer de la
gagne en force normalement la logique
veut que la mère décision soit
l'abandonner et de repartir
j'ai quand même être le fourrage 6 sur
l'échec
je mets le rang 2
changer une fois le pu ranger 3 je vais
être une tour en d1 une tour ans est un
pion à trois je poussais c4 s'il fait b5
veut faire payer 5 et d 3 kg 5
pas malin comme plan bref trois tours un
jouet sur le sur la faiblesse ont eu six
nations b 5e j'ai vite j'ai vite trouvé
le plan je m
je m leroy f 3 cavaliers ses cages avec
la tour ans et deux ans à eux deux et le
quart alliance et 5 sachant que mon
cavalier défend de toute façon le pion
b2 et donc je vais tour ces deux tours 2
ce que je vais jouer un tour un tournoi
donc pour cette alors maintenant on va
faire un petit coup de hache 4 on va
prendre de l'espace
alors
comment on continue pas toujours simple
j'ai bien envie de faire des trois
chassé m lecavalier ici
ouais séjour un peu technique
c'est de la gagner propre pas toujours
simples en huit d'être propre mais on
essaie de prendre de l'espace petit à
petit degré des faiblesses ok je vais
pousser cas donc important que le roi
soit en cavalier par rapport aux fous
par rapport au machin maintenant
cavalier e 4 échecs il ya encore un
premier fils sa vague et ceux qui
apprécient son machin consiste en six
épreuves casse toi je prends axa gagne 1
qui est progressiste ou reif 8 tours
prend 1,6
tous rêvent sept tours cet esprit c'est
peut-être ça gagne pas à incroyable bon
c'est pas de chance
honnêtement c'est pas de chance allez on
va partir de ce côté là on va aller
jouer sur l'autre colonne mais je
voulais pas mettre mon fiancé 5 si
j'avais vu toute cette variante j'aurais
joué différemment
bon allez on va jouer pour la colonne b
maintenant ils étaient ressources foule
et à m'apprécier pas quel point il avait
tout prévu par un peu fort de café d'or
a vu tout ça mais bon il a bien placé
ses pièces s'est reproduite ici
je vais prendre une fois 5
ok
maintenant
alors si je fais tourbe est un échec
roy c'est cette force est tombée cet
échec croise et si ça j'ai calculé tour
contre sept cavaliers prendre 7 3 4 rois
princes et saint croix prend 1,5 et là
il ya cavaliers ces six échecs peut-être
droit aussi ce qu'elle ait des cas 3,17
je suis pas sûre de cette finale là avec
ses échecs un peu bizarre avec
lecavalier
elle doit gagner
bon il ya peut-être autre chose pour
elle j'ai juste envie de la voir en fait
cette finale elles m'intéressent du coup
c'est une finale qui m'intrigue
maintenant je peux aussi tu as joué
cavalier e 4 mais bon je veux rentrer
dans cette finale elles m'intrigue
peut-être je foire complètement quelque
chose mais maintenant je suis intrigué
par ce truc là
fait ça peut vous surprendre mais dans
ce truc un peu pédagogique des fois j'ai
envie de voir les positions que j'ai
calculé pour voir où on est et mes
calculs ce que j'ai vu ça et j'ai eu du
mal à juger en fait juste la finale en
soi est intéressante
juste parce que les rois sont placés de
manière bizarre ça rend ce truc
intriguant pour moi ça rend ce truc très
intrigant plus j'ai pu y a plus des
chats quelques cavaliers dont les
cavaliers 6 quai prend 1,7 par g4 et h5
je pense que le roi est très mal placé
angers 4 parce que j'ai cavaliers à 6 h
6 h 7 h 8 quai de faire un truc moi je
perds kf 6 et je fais rascisme ah mince
le roi part de l'autre côté et c'est
peut-être nul du coup ah oui c'est nul
du coup droit ici et c'est nul
intéressant
alors commence à gagner commence à
gagner proprement
c'est intéressant comme finale c'est
pour ça que je les jouais ok pour gagner
ces cavaliers 4/4 et les c3 est sûrement
kébé 5 allait gagner le pion de l'autre
côté la gagner la finale était vraiment
très intéressante et peut-être la g5 je
sais pas mais la finale était très
intéressante et c'est sûrement plus
facile de gagner sans rentrer dans la
finale du cavalier mais c'était vraiment
très intéressant
très intéressant très intéressante come
back up final alors jouer un petit peu
agressif sur la fin pour essayer de
rattraper
ouais c'était cool comme finale état
déjà bien défendu c'était intéressant
ferry inquiétez pas il y avait d'autres
finale il fallait faire ou quatre gardés
les tours j'avais juste envie de
regarder cette finale là par curiosité
et finalement j'ai faim j'ai bien fait
parce que du coup
[Musique]
du coup on a appris des trucs qu'on
avait une belle finale et c'était
intéressant jusqu'au bout avec le roi
qui partait de l'autre côté et où donc
c'était vraiment très intéressant et je
suis heureux d'avoir joué la finale
ça permet de voir d'autres choses ça
permet de voir d'autres choses
bon alors ici est-ce que prisent
prévenance apa j'ai envie d'essayer de
finir en à vous il ya d'apprendre matin
pourquoi j'ai fait ça en fait du coup
j'ai vu que ça marchait pas et puis je
le fais quand même bon ok on va faire un
échelon un truc comme ça
bon c'est pas extraordinaire en place et
séduit aura échec fait un échec encore
là je comprends pas pris la parole est
maintenant c'était c'est une finale
vraiment intéressante
la tour est protégée c'est important ça
peut aussi mais la dame en étroit et
qu'elle sait c'est qu'elle prend ses
trois quand même sur d'amis cima ce
matin mais je couvre est sûre d'un
beffroi qualité de échec du coup ça va
gagner vite mais bon rattrapera pas le
premier on gagnera pas le tournoi
on gagnera pas le tournoi puisque pas
grave
outre mesure a pas forcément jouer
agressif et tous les arénas faut avoir
un style un peu spécifique pour les
gagner je vais plus agressif on verra
celle de ce soir à 21h
4 3
ce que je peux en faire mais le roi au
centre qui prend je prends après j'aurai
tour f8 qui risque de faire mal
je n'ai pas vu ça mais mon toit fuit de
sa gamme
peut ne pas être idiot de de la gagne
pour un cadre
autour des 4 allez hop on rattrapera pas
on rattrapera pas mc de maths en un sas
est couvert à les killers mania c'est de
prélever un peu de partout c'est
promouvoir ce qui va nous faire killer
magna qui va attaquer à fond on va faire
un truc marrant on va remettre le carré
en b1 pour garder le contrôle de la
casse ces quatre ça peut être fun quoi
comme ça en fait un paquet laissé 4
voilà attaquer à fond de l'autre côté
mais là je laisse la casse des cinq
peut-être qui sait le carignan h quatre
ans il s'en prendre à ça
alors oui c'est de passer un petit coup
d'accélérateur dans ce tournoi foot est
roi
pour mme ans pas très grave
ce pion restant en vie façon hyper du
temps il faut 5 lui même
ok je faire dame f2 comme ça je veux
faire qu'il prend h4 et en plus je me
place peut-être pourtour f1 et attaquer
ici donc je cueille proches quatre
gagnants qui ont quand même maintenant
d'après qu'étrangers 6 c'est vrai
pompier prend h4 peut-être club prend
des quatre qui effectue on prend des
quatre direct qui a mené pas bête
on va faire prend qui avec l'idée que ça
ça peut rester en prise à un moment
donné
il ya peut-être pas si clair clair genre
vous prend dimpre en camaïeu 5.5
comprend 1,5 d'un prend des 8,3 prend
des 8es roi bouge ok alors là j'ai envie
de faire j'ai envie de faire cavalier
prend premier
ok sur cahier prend il ya vous prend
donc ça c'est inévitable puis on prend
ces shorts en fait assez nigel dans les
variantes achoui nigel de chez nigel
ouais je suis shirt de pas grand chose
pour f1 touret fuite
ça serait joli si ça marche et y'a rien
qui marche
ok je peux juste faire flouer 3 et
préparer tour f1 soir était pièce noire
passe quand même très mal placé il n'y a
pas d' attaque sur mon roi et là je
juste tour f1 provoqué touré fuite est
allé prendra jusqu'à 13,5 si je prends
h4 déjà après je contourne avec d'un
match 7 et les pièces noires sont un peu
mal classés parce que dura déplacer
genre fois assise bon je m'en fous je
peux juste prendre et du coup je
voudrais encore un clouage cavaliers
bouge c'est pas possible il faut prendre
et si ce cavalier il a pas de case il
faut à 6 c'est ce que je disais je m'en
fous je prends une fois et je fais tout
à la fin
il se trouve qu'il ya encore dame e7 qui
défend ouais j'aurais peut-être dû être
plus précis un petit manque de
concentration
je pensais que c'était finirait j'aurais
dû but est plus fort gros manque de
concentration
soyons honnêtes alcaide 2 mais ces
fautes professionnelles d'avoir fait
faux bond à 6 tempo bizarre je pensais
que je pouvais gagner ça plus en force
qu'ai je vais tenter dames 2 j'avoue
j'ai cassé quatre je vais essayer de
m'introduire avec la dame sur les cases
blanches noter que le roi noir peu par
ok de ce côté là parce que la tour a
déjà bougé vont vous connaissez les
règles mais c'est quand même important
il peut par ok de l'autre côté
donc après qui prend ses quatre d'un
prince et 4g encore ajouter des menaces
et mes pièces s'approche de plus en plus
et je vais doubler les tours sur une des
deux colonnes mon four 3 je le garde
pour parce qu'ils contrôlent la dame
quelques pas c'est un genre d'antidote
contre la dame si vous voyez la dame et
le fou font la même chose ici et mon
cavalier madame 2002 cavaliers et là je
veux juste dame français 6 et surtour
s'est vite je vais faire juste tour d2
mais qui déçoit tous rêvent de soi tour
des 1
donc on va augmenter la pression
sachant qu'un vous comme dame assise
ceci peut être sympa mais on va rester
sur tours d2 menace rien avec force les
menaces de menacer ce que to have the
tour f cell j'ai l'impression que c'est
très chiant et surtout refi tu mettrais
la tour en d1 et je vais switcher pour
attaquer de l'autre côté sur la colonne
d
comme ça après je pourrais faire tour
des six peut-être est menacée à tout
reprend g6 où tout réussit ce cas de
fuite aura j'ai très envie de faire
c'est 5 avec idées sur dame pranger 5e
c'est pour ça que j'avais mis la tour d2
pour éviter l'échec et j'aurai tout
reprend 1,8 point en fuite et dames 6
donc là ça se précise
les menaces se multiplient mais qui
l'armagnac il abandonne donc c'était une
partie sympa encore une fois c'est une
partie que j'ai trouvé sympa une
nouvelle fois et tours d2 j'ai bien aimé
avec l'idée que sur d'alger sur dame
pranger 5e et pallier pas le truc quoi
être très loin d'arthur et lucas qui a
tout gagné et il fera un tueur il est
fort cet arthur s'est joué très vite
pour gagner encore une
il est très fort cet arthur qui est des
cinq l'ont par la suite bon avoir vu
contre renault 31 84 enfin je crois
plutôt écoutez j'ai trouvé le ton est
très sympa tu pas ce que vous en avez
pensé moi je me suis fait plaisir je
fromage ou des belles positions des
parties intéressantes
j'espère avoir bien expliqué ce que je
faisais nous avoir aidés à l'amphi d'un
pion gratuit on lui laisse faut prendre
trois d'un point trois fous projet 4
pour aller attaquer son roi j'espère que
ça vous a plu
alors il prend pas le pion du coup on va
faire h3 on va consolider on va faire
est de 4,5
je pense qu'il aurait dû prendre
j'aurais pu faire j'ai ça mais je peux
faire g5 et puis j'ai juré pu qualifier
4 à ok il veut faire d'un mec 3 ok
peut-être ça justifie quelques petits
trucs mais j'y crois pas il ya plusieurs
écoles mais une école c'est de prendre
laisser prendre effet requis et b5
ça c'est l'école tu peux pas défendre
ton pioncer 7
et si tu pousses ya des six ans prise un
petit chipeau tactique qui fait plaise
joli hein pas joli pas très difficile
mais thématique genre un pas si facile à
voir mais c'est sympa de faire ce petit
truc pédagogique tous très pédagogique
la dea du coup en plus ça crée un
deuxième problème c'est du coup le pion
des six est arriérée donc c'est vraiment
g
ça devrait nous rapporter une victoire
tout ça
moi je met le 2 je vais et ceux qui
allaient sortir je vais chasser
si on s'écarte jeu vers chasser il vient
en trois jeux fermer ces trois
tranquille
rien de très compliqué
tu faire tourner un quand même
ok de faire c'est ok je faire ces trois
prophylactique akingbala tour la vraie
qui à trois reprises avec et ses six
tours des cinq qui a eu trois tombes et
5 et à si je vais prendre ici et faire
qu'ils aient des deux avec des jantes ou
recevions là et maintenant
ouais sur ça je fais tour ici kg 6 tout
vaccin protège le pion et je vais aller
choper c4 et peut-être des cinq qui
étaient plus forts mais prises et
j'aurai quand même pris ces quatre ce
serait aller et maintenant et je prends
l'arrière pas de problème je protège
sayah c4 qui tombe il ya tout qui tombe
fait un petit coup de dés 6 que t'es pas
obligatoire mais qui sait si l'on prend
comme ça quand il reprend la tour je
recolle un petit cavalier e 4
c'est qu'un essai 5 ou même pas on va
faire tourner un qui est peut-être plus
fort encore elle m'a donc aidé si on va
être obligé de proposer nul parce que
c'est la fin du tournoi on reprendre un
dernier point et il a refusé et il a
abandonné et donc on finit loin et on
aura payé notre notre mauvais prêts move
et un autre a pareillement pas si facile
mauvais prêts mouais ça coûte à un point
et puis éteindre qui nous attire une
petite nul c'est un par une partie sympa
donc où il fallait sûrement pas échangé
de l'électorat partie d'état né va pas
échanger tour est joué le truc que je
pensais plus fort 3 ou 4 3 des trois c4
garder les tourelles à gagner comme ça
c'est ce que j'aurais sûrement fait mais
j'étais curieux de la finale de cavalli
et du cou à cette partie aux anges et 4
pourquoi pas fou qu'on a trois prises
aux 3 pourquoi pas prendre le pion g4
finalement c'était peut-être intéressant
je bouge la tour mais ça doit être
pipeau ce sacrifice même si tu as our
une colonne et à devant le roi bon tu
gagnes un pion c'est pas si facile de
pousser et après ouais c'est un petit
truc avec cavaliers b5 à connaître quand
on attaque ses sept comme le fouet pas
développé on peut pas de protéger si on
pousse on perd des six donc ouais donc
intéressant ouais merci et anne bah
écoute j'essayais donc au musée la
finale je pense y aura des cas droit
qu'à trois des trois rois as etc
argumente le truc à mon avis ça gagne
sans trop de soucis mais la finale de
cavani me paraissait vraiment
intéressante donc j'avais envie de la
jouer
sympa si tu l'analyse tu veux progresser
n'hésite pas à l'analyse et à regarder
comment les blancs auraient dû gagner
je pense que ça doit être gagnant mais
le roi et bizarrement placée derrière
les pions tel fallait partir vers le
pion à mais bon je sais pas c'était
intéressant c'était vraiment intéressant
donc une finale une finale assez cool et
bravo à ces arthur lucas qui a gagné
pour sa victoire dans le tournoi donc on
se retrouve pour la vraie arena d'une
petite demi-heure ciao ciao les mecs